it is Jerry it's me not an imposter I am
in line at the gas station so I'm being
safe today uh-huh and I figured I would
talk to you briefly about Noah cuz I
just saw noah last week and I got to
attend a screening of this so I figured
why not talk about it uh so yeah noah
darren aronofsky's noah darren aronofsky
a professional famous for films like pie
and requiem for a dream and the wrestler
and Black Swan is doing this movie and
uh it's pretty cool it I liked it more
than I thought I was gonna the trailer
sort of made it look like Ridley Scott's
Robin Hood to me which I donors for some
reason kind of looked right and
uninteresting but um there's a lot more
going on that I thought there would be
this movie has really cool style is
probably what what stood out to me the
most it's got this interesting visual
flair and these recurrent montages and
sort of glucerna tori dream sequences
that i thought were really cool I know
his goal he said like you know when the
the Bible stories talk about God
speaking to people speaking is kind of a
loose translation of that word so you
know it would be more like he would come
to them and convey messages in dreams
and through imagery and stuff like that
so I like that they incorporated that
you know instead of just having this guy
open up and having a big dude be like no
uh you must [ __ ] save [ __ ] you know
it does have that sort of epic how might
this actually have looked feel to it um
but it's still got a certain element of
I guess you'd call it fantasy I mean
there are certain you know miraculous
things that happen over the course of
the movie that are interesting the cast
is all really good uh you know Russell
Crowe is great Jennifer Connelly's great
ray winstone is great logan lerman and
emma watson and i forget the actor who
played the other son everybody does a
good job in this movie acting wise and
the direction is certainly confident
this story is interesting to me as I
remember the story of Noah is not super
dense in the Bible as I recall it but
you
they do kind of expand that mythology if
you want to call it that in some ways
that are really cool you know Adam and
Eve had three sons cable and Seth and
you know Cain killed Abel blah blah blah
so now the bloodline of Cain and the
bloodline of Seth have sort of endured
and they're these tribes essentially um
and that's that's kind of a cool way to
look at this and it gives an interesting
sort of antagonistic bend to the story
there were some things I wasn't
expecting there they're these big
Guardian rock creatures these fallen
angels that I thought were actually
really cool it might be hard for some
people to swallow but i thought those
really cool what took me aback about
this movie is the fact that in the
second half it goes completely insane
which part of me really does like but
it's like they get to a certain point
they build the ark they get on the ark
and that's not the whole movie you know
after that there's this sort of like
Abraham esque thing I don't want to give
too much away but there is some insanity
which sort of takes hold of the story
there and part of me really likes it i
mean the performances are all great you
can really see the struggle and the
whole hearted deranged pneus that takes
over noah and then that starts to grip
his family and there are some
interesting conflicts that are brought
up in here it just tonally for me it was
sort of a left turn so that's the part
of the movie where darren aronofsky
really gets to be darren aronofsky
because his movie sort of always come
back to people sort of destroying
themselves and going down these these
spiral asst pits into the abyss of
obsession and self-destruction so this
movie does have some of that and it
becomes rather harrowing um I just I
don't know if I fully feel like the two
halves of the movie fit together like
the logic makes sense but something I'm
still trying to process that but it's a
it's an interesting movie it's more
interesting than I thought it was gonna
be I liked it more than I thought I
would everyone involved is a great job
and there's some really cool visual
sequences and montages and stuff um so
yeah that's that's Noah for me as of
right now um let me know what you
thought um what's your you know I mean
people kind of [ __ ] on Bible movies or
faith-based movies but let's talk about
that do you guys
like particularly any Bible or
faith-based or or any other you know
faith-based movie a whole lot for any
reason and as always comment subscribe
and yeah Noah i'm gerry until next time
chucha cheers